Sí definitivamente
el calentamiento global es un efecto que
se siente mucho más fuerte en este país
del norte de de continente y lo hemos
visto en los últimos años en este caso
estos incendios forestales en esta
provincia de Alberta lo comprueban las
temperaturas récord que se han tenido
por ejemplo netmo montón al inicio de
este mes de casi 29 grados fue una
primavera incitada con una sequía
también muy fuerte en el que
evidentemente el calentamiento global
los efectos de gases invernadero que se
están generando a razón de todo este CO2
emanado de los incendios pues tienen
estos efectos obviamente los efectos
climatilos climatológicos son muy
evidentes pero también los efectos
sociales y los efectos económicos ya que
como se menciona pues Alberta es una
región petrolera en el que se ha
disminuido no tan grave aproximadamente
no más de un cinco por ciento la
producción del petróleo no se han tenido
daño significativos en en las zonas
petroleras sin embargo está mermando
esta producción a razón de esta
prohibición de una mayor catástrofe es
un estado de emergencia que la primer
ministra
a razón de de solicitar la ayuda del
Gobierno Federal
creo que es un es Es evidente que se
está escalando y sobre todo que todavía
hay más de una veintena de incendios que
todavía no están controlados eso es
importante puntualizarlo porque pues
todavía no
esquema un esquema de certeza sobre este
tipo de incendios